PROFESSOR: We have the
hydrogen atom Hamiltonian.
Hamiltonian.
And that was given by
the kinetic operator
for the proton plus
for the electron plus
the potential, which
was a function of the
distance between the proton
and the electron.
And what we achieved last
time was the introduction
of two new pairs of
canonical variables.
We had the electron
position momentum, that's
a pair of canonical variables.
The proton position
and momentum,
that's another pair of
canonical variables.
They commute each
pair, the two operators
commute to give IH bar, but
the two pairs are independent.
So we search for another
two pairs of variables,
and we found another two pairs.
One was the P and X associated
with the center of mass motion,
and then we had the small
p and small x associated
with the relative function.
And these four variables were
a function of the original four
variables, the X and
P of the electron
and the x and p of the proton.
So we define these two pairs,
and they were canonical pairs.
This x with this p gave
IH bar, this x with this p
gave IH bar, these p's and x's
commute with any combination
of p's and x's over there.
But not only was
that pretty good,
it simplified the Hamiltonian.
So at the end of the day,
we had a Hamiltonian,
which was as if the center of
mass moves like a free particle
plus a kinetic energy
for the relative motion,
with a mass called
the renews mass,
and the potential for
the relative position.
And here, the mass, capital M,
was the sum of the two masses.
And the relative
mass was the product
of the masses over
the sum, which
has the property that
if one of the two masses
is much bigger
than the other, it
gives you a mass mu proportional
roughly equal to the lower
mass.
So this is the hydrogen
atom reformulated.
And now, we want to write
the Schrodinger equation
and just see effectively how the
central potential formulation
of the relative motion arises.
Although, it starts to be
a little somewhat clearer,
I think, that that's
going to happen.
Another thing to
notice of course,
is that if you're already
thinking of a Schrodinger
equation, in which
you will think
of the momenta as the
derivative operators,
the center of mass
momentum should
be thought as the derivative
operator with respect
to the center of mass position.
So think of the center of
mass as three coordinates,
and you differentiate
with respect to them.
Similarly, for the
relative momentum,
we'll think of it as a
gradient with respect
to the relative
position, because that's
the canonical coordinate
that goes along with it.
That's how we should think of
this operator as derivative.
And before, we didn't have
to put those subscripts
in [INAUDIBLE],, because we
always had just one coordinate
to work with.
But now, you have
two coordinates.
What you've learned here
in doing this analysis
was that we have a wave function
that has coordinate dependence
on both the electron
and the proton.
So let's do the separation
of variables that shows
how to deal with this system.
So you want to write the wave
function for the whole system,
so it depends on
the center of mass
and on the relative coordinates.
Now, I don't put
time, because we're
discussing time independent
Schrodinger equation, where
the time you can
put it later, if you
wish, with the total
energy into the minus IET.
So what we will consider
is a simple solution
that is of the product type.
So there will be a wave
function associated up
factor, which is a wave function
associated with center of mass,
and the wave function associated
to the relative motion.
And we want to replace this
into the Schrodinger equation
into H psi equals E psi.
So let's see how it would go.
Each term of the
Hamiltonian is going
to act on this product of
functions that determines
the whole wave function.
The center of mass
momentum, being
derivative, respect to
this x, will act just
on the first term.
So we'll have p squared over
2 m acting on psi c m of x.
And the relative wave
function in that term
just goes for the ride.
So that's the first
term in the Hamiltonian.
For the second term
in the Hamiltonian,
we would have p
squared over 2 mu.
We could add them psi
relative, and let's put
even the potential
here, v of x relative--
we don't put the relative
on the x, but they'll just--
it's a small x
psi relative of x.
So we've looked at the second
term and the third term.
The third term is
grouped with the second,
because it uses the
little x, not the big X.
And then you have psi
cm of x multiplicativly,
it doesn't do anything to it.
All this is equal to
e times the psi cm
of x psi relative of little x.
OK, that's the
Schrodinger equation.
And this should remind you,
it's very similar to what
you did months ago of having
motion's in say, in two
dimensions, and you wrote part
of the wave function dependant
on x, part of a wave
function dependant on y,
and you separated the
Schrodinger equation.
So the next thing to do is
to divide by the total wave
function, by the product.
So divide 5 by the
total wave function.
So what do you get?
From the first
term, you will get 1
over psi cm of capital X times
this p squared over 2 m psi
cm of capital X. And that's all
what comes of the first term.
From the second, you get
plus 1 over psi relative
of x and this whole
bracket squared
over 2 mu psi relative
plus V of x psi relative.
And the whole thing being equal
to E. The two wave functions
are divided there.
So we have a situation
where a number
is the sum of two functions.
Now, what is funny of
course, is the argument
you've heard several times.
This first term depends just
on the capital X-coordinates.
The second term depends just
on the lower x-coordinates,
small x-coordinates.
I didn't write them in some
places, but here they are.
And therefore, the only way
these two things can always
be true, is if the
first term is a number.
And we'll call it Ecm.
The whole thing must be a
number, we'll call it Ecm.
And the second term
should be another number,
and I'll call it E relative.
That's E relative.
So our conclusion is that
if this first term is
a number equal to Ecm we
can multiply by psi cm
and get p squared over
to 2m psi cm of x is
equal to Ecm times psi cm of x.
Which is a time independent
Schrodinger equation
for a wave function psi
cm that is moving freely.
The next equation is
the one within brackets,
which is p squared over 2 mu
psi relative of x plus v of--
now I can put r, when I
say that r is the magnitude
of x psi relative of
x equals e relative--
I should move this--
psi relative of x.
And we said that r was this.
So the second equation
comes from this term
identified with relative.
And the last equation is to
say that the total energy is
equal to Ecm plus e relative.
So the whole two body
problem has been reduced
to these three equations.
This is what we aim to show.
This is a gradient squared
on this wave function,
the central potential term,
and the rest of the Schrodinger
equation.
So this is a
Schrodinger equation
for a particle in the
central potential.
That particle happens to
be the relative distance
between these two particles,
but it obeys a central equation
potential.
Here is the center of mass.
Solutions of this is a plane
wave, momentum plane waves,
because this is like
a free particle,
and that's our intuition.
The hydrogen atom can
move like a free particle.
That's an overall
quantum system and then
there's the relative
degrees of freedom.
The total energy of this system
must be the sum of the two.
So that said for the
system, we are allowed now,
to consider the hydrogen atoms.
So that's what we'll do next.